to play the instrument that is utilizing  our gentle earth it's like you are  becoming one with the instrument in a  very true way you just sit and go yes  we're looking at the grades to like pipe  organ of the Luray Caverns in Luray  Virginia when I press a key it sends an  electrical pulse up to a rubber tipped  mallet which strikes the stalactite  causing it to vibrate and producing a  incredibly beautiful musical tone the  area that the strikers cover is roughly  three and a half acres which then makes  it literally the world's largest musical  instrument it is a very gentle sound of  very peaceful there's only one like it  in the world and it's something  incredibly different and wonderfully  beautiful